hey guys and welcome back to the Leia
heilpan show joining me on the show
today some might know him as Andrew
Tate's right hand man he's a security
expert he's ex-military loves shooting
guns wearing incredible Rolexes and he
loves traveling the world in style
joining on the show today we have
sartorial shooter Jules welcome to the
show how are you quite the intro thank
you all is good good to be here I've
watched a lot of your shows so it's good
good to meet you guys good to be here
yeah it's great to finally meet you we
finally connected when the whole Andrew
Tate thing just blew up and it's been so
it's been a pleasure to kind of Meet the
other people behind the scenes and and
understand more about the mechanics of
everything so solid team definitely yeah
absolutely so you're in Miami before we
get into everything I just want to know
how are you enjoying it here how what
are the differences to device I like
well there's a lot of rain that's that's
different it is it's not usually like
this I promise you oh cool we don't get
much rain in the desert I like it here I
view it as a bit of a sister city to
Dubai it's just Dubai's cleaner and
safer and ideologically I'm more aligned
with you know the Middle East that I'm
over here but I can see that you can
definitely live a good life here it's a
you know there's a good crowd as well
I've met some great people I can see
that there's a there's a good life to be
had here definitely yeah it's beautiful
here I do look at um Miami and Dubai as
the sister cities they're very similar
um but let's get into it I want to know
more about you I I did know of you
before Andrew was canceled because you
know I follow a lot of his stuff his
content so I can always like see who the
different faces are but you know we
finally connected during the spaces when
we're all that like defending Andrews
right yeah yeah we did the spaces
together but who is sartorial shooter
what is your background so in terms of
who I am I mean I'm here to represent
the tape brothers and the war room and
I'm here with you because of your
support with the dates I really
appreciate how loud you went a lot of
people weren't quiet when you know when
all the nonsense came up around the
false allegations with the tapes whereas
you went even louder so I really respect
that which is great uh background yeah
Australian Army I started as a soldier
and then went into the intelligence
world I don't really talk about that
much because it was a long time ago and
people get a bit weird when you talk
about all things intelligence so I'm a
private security sector professional
I've worked across the Middle Eastern
Africa and pretty much every active War
Zone in the last 15 years
and yeah I solve tricky problems in
tricky countries that's the way I
explain it and and for those who wanted
to understand more about the security
industry you could Google things like
threat management uh kidnap and response
crisis management evacuations or all
these sorts of things that are what I
lead at the management level now I still
deploy when needed I still do some some
surveillance work some executive
protection work but generally speaking
I'm management and I manage different
assets different resources around the
world
so explain to me how you ended up
meeting the Tates I believe you met
about five years ago exactly five years
ago yeah and how has he impacted your
life oh right okay so first of all how I
met them five years ago I had something
I needed to resolve in Romania I
contacted Tate on social media I didn't
really have any any contacts there he
helped out in a way I said look as a
gesture of my thanks come over to one of
my facilities in Ukraine I have various
weapons and tactics training facilities
around the world and we did some pretty
intense shooting I think I earmarked
about 2 000 rounds for the three days
but we went through eight thousand of
these guys it was dawn to dusk and then
some very little asleep a lot of
drinking back then thankfully that's all
behind us
um and I realized these guys were built
different they're very high level of
both mental and physical capability but
at the end of that it was Tristan's
birthday we're sitting in a cigar lounge
and I heard them both speaking with such
insight and such uh clear-cut analysis
of things like the war masculinity on
you know the failing West and I said to
them guys you have a leadership role to
play in terms of masculinity in terms of
you know combating wokeness and all
these things I'll support however I can
now for the longest time I was a guy in
the background I was fine with that
however when they were
um detained and all these Twitter spaces
that was the first time I really went
loud and to speak up for Andrew and you
know as a result was docs so I don't
need to say you know hide behind satello
shoot anymore I can actually say my name
but uh it's because of the fact that
I've been around the Tate so much you
know more than anyone outside their
family for the last five years and
because I know the real Tates all these
experts these investigators these
journalists pretending to understand who
Tate is I know I've been there and I'm
I'm a credible source of you know
analyzing who a person is and isn't so
that's why I'm here that's why I've gone
loud as to how Tate has impacted my life
Wow many different ways and often talk
about the importance of Brotherhood I
think as men you need to find other men
on the same level as you to go and you
know conquer the world and so on that's
based on the dynamic Andrew and Tristan
have their strong Brotherhood and also
within the war and the organization
they've created we promote that that
concept of having a brother there who's
not only pushing you but also catching
you if you slip up but also that living
in that masculine frame the example
being if you if you wake up and you you
know your brother goes to the gym at
seven in the morning you're not going to
sit there and watch you're gonna do it
as well right so that idea of healthy
male competition in a supportive sort of
Brotherhood that has absolutely
revolutionized pretty much every area of
my life and the organization that they
created the War Room we've got so many
capable men in there always sharing
insights and advice whether it's
finances or Fitness or parenting you
name it you know life hacks all these
things so much knowledge has been drawn
from both what I call technology and
from the War Room information sharing
pretty much every area of my life has
been positively impacted so that's why I
speak of it so highly it's it's I am
living proof of the power of the tape
message to take you from that sort of
vanilla existence into someone who's
created what I call a custom-made
reality if you if you follow the tenants
of Tate if you you get the right
Brothers around you you can absolutely
transform your life as I have done over
the last five years
this is so interesting to me the war and
masculinity and we're gonna get to that
um so it will do that but I just want to
go back a little bit um to your newfound
stardom
um you know you're a security guy you're
the type of person that wants to be you
know behind the scenes and I understand
that and I get that and sometimes I sort
of wish I was behind the scenes actually
um but how are you enjoying the Newfound
stardom that you have I I have to say a
bit conflicted but for the longest of
time even though I'm six foot six I'm
quite tall it was an issue on certain
types of tasks like if you're doing
surveillance and you're told on everyone
you're going to stand out right yeah so
I always put a lot of energy in being
the guy in the background
um for you know many different tasks I'd
grow my hair out or I dress in a certain
way that you know didn't didn't stand
out obviously all that's gone now
I'm okay with being recognized publicly
even though it goes against you know who
I've been for so many years because the
reason I'm being recognized is very
positive the amount of people who come
up to the Tates and now are coming up to
me and all I'm doing is pushing you know
the take principles and the tape message
just last night we were in a night
before actually in a restaurant one of
the waiters spoke for two minutes about
how one of my my videos had possibly
impacted his life it was really touching
like that's a real so I don't really
need people coming up to me in public
I'm not a fan of it but if it ties into
you know spreading that positive message
and changing people's lives for the
better I'll accept it that's fine but
yeah one day my my everything will get
canceled I'm sure because I'm not going
to stop supporting Tate so my Instagram
will be canceled my YouTube will be
canceled fine good life will be simpler
yeah I'm okay with that as well I'm with
you and it's funny because a lot of
people often you know say that Tate's
message is dangerous I interview
somebody who once said the war room is
um is a gang of men that's what I've
heard sounds good actually yeah well you
know with negative evil connotations
um but it's funny because I have the
same experience as I'm walking around
life I have people come up to me and say
oh I recognize you from the stuff you
say about Andrew Tate I want to thank
you and every single person that comes
out to me is well spoken they're polite
they're complementary and they know
boundaries they're not trying to be
weird with me they're respectful and to
me that's the epitome of Tate's message
exactly professionalism refinement
stoicism being the man who looks after
his people it's all very positive and
all these journalists who want to claim
that takes messages somehow negative
have a look at the comments under just
about any Tate video there are so many
people saying both men and women that
they agree with these messages had
positive impacts on their lives it's got
them back in the gym it's helped them
you know reunite with with family
members that they were estranged with
it's helped them work harder it's
nothing but positivity yes some of the
things he said back in the day where
he's trying to build build that that
character okay if misinterpreted they
could be negative I think young men of
today are a little smarter than people
are giving credit I think they know when
he's playing that gangster rapper
character because if they don't then we
should ban all gangster rappers which
ban on violent video games we should ban
all pornography like if young men of
today are unable to see whether
something's literal or something's
entertainment then we need to stop a lot
more than just Andrew Tate's messages
yeah we need to stop cardi B yeah oh my
God she's terrible when you're still
cardi B she's actually admitted to
crimes too she's drugged and robbed
people but she's out there winning
Awards it's just such a nonsense and I
have to believe that the majority of
people see how much nonsense is out
there even though the leftists and the
haters the ones who are most loud on
social media I'd have to believe you
know the average person the majority of
this species can pick the nonsense
leftist woke us not you know just
rubbish as opposed to someone speaking
truth and that's why the tapes are
popular it's not because they say
misogynistic things it's because they're
one of the few people with such
influence speaking truth and speaking
what everyone else is thinking anyway
there's nothing mysterious there they're
just saying what everyone else thinks
but doesn't have the the testicular
fortitude to say or courage let's let's
make it a gender-neutral term
you're in a safe space you can say
whatever you like we're in a
conservative safe
exactly so I
aggressive online saying very
controversial things and now it seems to
be very much more The Matrix I'm talking
about you know inflation which I which I
love that he's talking about
um you know he's talking about how
governments are suppressing oppressing
the people
um you know depression's not real all
this like amazing stuff
what's his goal okay so back in the day
it was to make money when I met him you
know five years ago to make money it's
not money anymore I mean look he still
likes the conquest involved in money but
he's got enough money now he's doing
fine financially which is great
um now it really is it's a calling he
feels it's his obligation to wake people
up he feels that he has no choice other
than to speak truth to power so to speak
and and people love it as a result also
a lot of people who want to understand
Tate's true intent check out Tate's
final message on Rumble that's where he
says things like look when I was
speaking to 5 000 followers it's
different to how I'm speaking to
Millions like you know he has that
self-awareness he's very responsible
with his his word choice now that he's
got you know Global influence and also
check out the 41 tenants of Tate on his
website on COBRA tate.com it clearly
outlines the beliefs that he thinks
every man should live by that of
stoicism as I mentioned mental
resilience looking after your people the
importance of Brotherhood all these
different things the importance of
self-sovereignty as to what you put into
your body you know all of these things
are out there his beliefs are very
clearly outlined but the journalists of
the world don't touch on that you know
they think they know better than Tate
when Tate is mapping out his own belief
systems you can see her right there but
no one wants to speak about these
positive elements so yeah I really do
believe that the Tates feel driven from
like a higher calling now to speak
against the Matrix and to wake people up
and let's face it not many other people
are who else is speaking to young men of
today and putting forward that
traditional masculine yes if you want to
be the guy with muscles and the pretty
girl you're in the nice car there's
nothing wrong with that if you want to
lift weights and fight in the ring
there's nothing wrong with that Tate is
speaking in a world where masculine
Heroes have been taken away I mean even
nowadays we don't even have real
masculine figures in in movies it's all
gone Tate's one of the only masculine
role models actually speaking clearly to
what young men are looking for which is
the hey I'd like to live like that and
hey maybe it is okay to want to be
strong and and have a you know a lovely
woman next to me it's okay to want these
things I think it's quite powerful we've
all heard about the war on masculinity
in today's world free thoughts
questioning the narrative and
traditional masculinity is criticized
why because it threatens the control of
those in power to maintain this control
all platforms from media to
entertainment have been harnessed to
propagate a narrative that dilutes
masculinity just like Andrew Tate and
the Sartorius shooter are doing we need
to wake people up testosterone levels
have been declining for decades with a
17 drop among 60 roles in 2004 compared
to 1987. to combat the war on
masculinity it's essential to focus on
activities that promote masculinity and
healthy testosterone levels like lifting
weights and getting high quality sleep
but another solution for you is Black
Forest to castrone and black forestry
staunch black forest testosterone is a
natural anabolic compound that supports
muscle growth improves endurance and
increases strength testosterone lean
muscle mass and AIDS in fat loss it's
like steroids but without any of the
nasty side effects although testosterone
is non-hormonal and can also be taken by
women for the ladies I recommend Black
Forest turbulosa its natural
non-hormonal supplement that can
actually help improve energy levels it
can boost the immune system and support
healthy aging Black Forest supplements
is a brand dedicated to this fight
they're on a mission to bring back
traditional masculinity and femininity
you can visit their website and use the
code layer at checkout for a 10 discount
check the pin comment in the description
below for the link and the discount code
stay strong stay informed and fight back
against those who seek to control and
manipulate us as a woman I loved his
message for that reason awesome because
there aren't many masculine men left I
saw a meme online and it was like the
heroes of the 70s you had like Arnold
Schwarzenegger you had um what's the
other guy thank you that's exactly I was
thinking of yeah Sylvester Stallone you
have Bruce Willis like you had these
like strong like masculine muscular men
and then now we have like skinny
Spider-Man who literally is having
therapy and a mother's meeting during
the Spider-Man thing yeah I can't watch
those movies I just can't watch them and
I mean even Arnie's gone veggio and he's
all left just now like it's terrible
yeah yeah everybody everybody has been
corrupted and actually that leads me on
to a question which I don't have written
down but it's just come to me now I want
to ask this a lot of the people who were
very controversial back in the day like
Arnold Schwarzenegger was quite
controversial with his masculinity and
everything yeah yeah yeah and you know
with the and the women and all this
stuff
now he's kind of quite establishment
telling people to lock down take their
medicines and things like that so my
question to you is
do you think Tate could ever get to you
know in 30 years from now and he's you
know an old man in his 60s or whatever
do you think he could ever you know
become not establishment but
as everybody gets older the the the
um the public perspective changes and
everyone I think will eventually love
Tate the way they love all those
controversial characters back in the day
I agree
do you think he could ever you know be
on the side of that yeah because I say
not as I do preaching that Tate is so
tight that I don't think he'll ever
change like a lot of people try and same
as manager you try managing tape like
tape that both the Tates are gonna do
what the Tate's gonna do they will never
change they'll never become an
establishment and to your point I mean
I've spent a lot of time living in
countries that are you know the old
school dictatorship I've lived in Syria
I've lived in Iran you know places where
you need to put up the face of the
leader on the wall and you need to show
your fealty to that leader otherwise
you're in trouble in the west that
leader up on the wall is wokism it is
this modern day degeneracy Tate will
never bow to that ever he he sees what
it is it's a system of control over the
masses it is modern day communism it is
a form of thought dictatorship if you
will and he lives to fight against that
so he could never become mainstream I I
I know for a fact that he will give up
everything he has including his own
personal freedom to continue to push his
message which is
anti-wokism sheep Matrix programming all
these things so he is committed to his
final breath that's that's not an act
that's real and obviously you know him
really well so were you surprised when
the allegations came about
not really to be honest in that we all
knew some kind of allegations would come
I was a I was surprised at how
ridiculous they are the idea that
someone pushing a brigetting and flying
private has the time or intent or energy
to try and restrain someone or trick
someone to take their Tick Tock money
especially actually when the two main
complaints one of them said hey I want
to get famous on Tick Tock you know when
they were when they met in a strip club
in in London years ago and takes it
right I know a thing or two about
internet marketing what's more credible
it's a a multi-multi-millionaire trying
to like enslave someone or someone
saying to someone who's known to be good
at internet marketing hey I want to get
famous on Tick Tock yeah you know and
then there's the other main complaint
from what I understand was only in
Romania for a few days and was staying
in a hotel How would how does that
equate to trafficking so I was surprised
at the the allegations that came in were
so drastic and so laughable and so
illogical but we all knew that some sort
of play against him was coming I mean
that's how this works when you hit a
certain level of influence the system
comes after you if you don't bend the
knees so to speak if you don't put up
the the picture of the leader on the
wall and show your fealty to the leader
being you know wokism in the Modern Age
yeah it's incredible because there are
other men that that I know because
obviously I do the podcast so I
interview like men who are at the top of
their game and I've had people text me
about different guys just saying by the
way Leia stay away from that one he's
been um I've heard I've heard rumors
that he's involved in
um in like rape cases human trafficking
so like it's not just hate it's any man
on that reaches a certain level like you
said it becomes inevitable that's the
attack vector and that's why I often say
like on on podcasts young men of today
be careful who you let into your life
because each new person you let in that
can be a landmine that gets you 10 years
later if you become a public figure you
get a bunch of money someone can decide
hang on that consensual sex act that we
engaged in 10 years ago oh I've decided
it was rape and now your reputation can
be ruined it's ridiculous it's really
risky I say that's why I actually said
to my brother before he came to Miami I
was like listen like have fun here
please be careful that some of the women
here are insane I've told him to be
careful because it's crazy I think it's
also I mean I I again I don't want to
sound woke but I don't think you need to
gender it a certain amount of the
population will exhibit those dark trial
Tendencies You Know machiavellianism
psychopathies sociopathy they say it's
between two and four percent so if
you're a young man who runs through say
a hundred women you know two to four or
maybe more of those are going to be
textbook psychopath types who will lie
mind or whatever they need to do to ruin
your life just to get whether they want
some attention or they want some you
know they're on some weird drama role
play that they're doing or they want
some cash and look I I'm very pro-women
looking after themselves I've taught
literally thousands of women personal
security I have a daughter who I've
taught you know how to be very assertive
and also you know made sure she has
hands you know she's done a fight
training from an early age I'm very
pro-women knowing their boundaries and
knowing how to protect themselves there
are real cases out there where women are
actually impacted by real crimes that
gets impacted by all these false
allegations rubbish I think it's I think
it's a true evil thing to do and for
some reason in society there's no
deterrent not to make up lies you can
make up lie against a man it could be
found out oh well I wasn't really true
continue your life you know sometimes
there's there's consequences but most of
the time there's zero consequences for a
woman making false allegations against a
man that's extremely risky and that's
why I think anyone in the western is oh
not even the West now Romania is not
considered the worst and look what's
happening any man who is engaging in a
lot of relationships with a lot of
different women they need to be really
really careful because it nowadays it's
extremely risky especially if you're on
a path to wealth and being a public
figure I actually believe that any woman
who falsely accuses a man should be
given the same amount of jail time as
the man would be given for that exact
answer 100 a lot of it's irreparable
damage as well I mean look I I
personally think I'm not sure from how
to say it I think there's a 33 Cent
solution for rapists let's put it that
way 33 solution for rapist I don't know
what the price of a round is nowadays
but you know I I believe in the death
penalty for rapists I really do but also
in terms of those who make false
allegations against men
they can ruin a man's reputation his
relationships his online reputation
forever and there's no consequence that
that is ridiculous then something needs
to be done about that yeah no absolutely
I totally agree with you and one of the
things that obviously landed Andrew in
this situation is how how outspoken he's
been not just about government and
things like that but you know I know he
said things about women he and I think
you sort of said actually on this face
is that he likes to play this gangster
kind of role even though he he's not
that but he likes to play that and we we
know that we know that it that it's um
that it's a facade if you like or
whatever he's an Entertainer yeah he's
an Entertainer so so can you tell us who
is Andrew Tate really okay cool so from
five years of being around Andrew Tate
not once have I seen him be rude to
anyone ever now once have I seen him
raise his voice and again I've lived in
his house he's lived in my house if all
of this drastic stuff was happening I
would have heard it I would have seen it
again I'm professionally trained in
assessing people I'm pretty good at
picking up on whether someone is you
know a liability or not I wouldn't have
him in my life I I wouldn't be speaking
publicly for him if any of this nonsense
could even be true no not history or you
know if it was even possible he's deeply
respectful he takes care of his people
and again not once have I seen him be
rude even to a waiter a waitress now
once have I seen him ever get angry he
has complete emotional control the idea
that he's out there doing all this wild
and completely illogically
exploitative Behavior it's just it's so
not real and I've seen it firsthand
which again is why I'm sitting here and
going public with this sort of thing and
I want to talk about the vice interview
because that I actually reacted to that
that was phenomenal uh the reason I say
phenomenal is because the way the
takeaway that they that they took from
that was so interesting to me I watched
it and I see I saw you in it obviously
um and I see men just striving to do
better right there was a part where you
told the men to like get in the ring
there was no preparation and you just
have to fight and then the Met
afterwards were interviewed and they
said they were so happy that they did
that now they feel you know I can go
home to my wife I can go home to my my
kids and I feel accomplished I feel like
I'm mad I feel like I can and I'm like
wow this is amazing and then uh advice
is like they all seem terrified it
seemed like they were like pushed into
doing it like they were threatened they
were bullied right so what was your
involvement in that and what was your
overall take okay so one of the tenants
of Tate is it's Tate says I believe I
have the right to to put on or to
facilitate very challenging experiences
as a writer passage from and many
cultures around you know throughout
history and even today if you don't go
through some sort of struggle some sort
of right of passage as a young man
you're not officially a man of the tribe
there's a very powerful thing in putting
through men through a healthy amount of
struggle Society doesn't do that so in
the war room we do a lot of these things
and it's super satisfying I really enjoy
I I run some courses and some some
events that do similar the test was an
absolute Masterpiece in terms of really
confronting people with their fears and
really putting them through some healthy
struggle in a very risk managed way so
it's very professional watching our vice
guys coming in greatly enjoy themselves
but then afterwards Matt was this timid
little guy who in order to infiltrate
the warm I had to agree to get in the
cage fight I got on a phone call with
the head of Vice security yeah who does
what I do for vice and I said mate
Medics on standby professional fighters
everything's above board everything's
being run in a very
uh risk managed manner we can vouch that
you know nothing terrible will happen
yes it's going to be a fight but you
know it's not like the fight is going to
come in and try and stomp on his head or
something it's a professional setup the
vice head of security said okay great
Matt was sitting there again I drove him
around we picked him up we took care of
him in every way and then he wants to
portray that he was some victim who had
to fight did he have a good time he
loved it he absolutely that was real
Brotherhood there and even the guy
behind the camera Jamie said you know
what I see the good that you guys are
doing here yeah they were super positive
and they weren't pretending again I can
read when someone's playing they were
having a great time and Matt himself
found it to be a hugely formative
experience of course but as soon as we
came to that final interview which was
three hours and they only showed like
one minute of it which was me saying
this is rubbish and walking out having a
little little tantrum there uh all of
these questions came out and all of a
sudden he was back in work mode and
trying to yeah and also I'm sorry you
cannot verbally trip up Tate it was if
one of the biggest mistakes of my
professional career was not saying hey
we should film this Vice Docker because
for three hours Andrew just ate Matt
alive with ease just just verbally
destroyed him that would have gotten
more views than the whole Vice
documentary it was a masterpiece from
Tate but unfortunately it'll sit in the
vice archives forever they'll never
release that because it makes him look
so bad so the whole thing was just
laughable those guys saw the value of
what we're doing they had a great time
themselves they were very looked after
again I even spoke to their head of Vice
security to get approval and vice you
know the vice risk management people to
get approval for Matt to go into the
ring every we were working together to
facilitate an amazing experience but
Boom the snake character came out he's a
man without honor as you can see so what
went wrong like what I don't get
as well in the
Doctor Who Um so it was a map yeah
nobody trusted him but numerous people
and I was having to convince them look
if you want to talk to him you can but
then they try and portray it that I'm
controlling the narrative and stopping
advice from I had to convince people to
talk device because no one trustwise the
idea that I was somehow stopping the the
thing I was making it possible
um interesting yeah so it's just and
again when they became bankrupt my
goodness I had a good laugh when I saw
that yeah it's reality wins in the end
you know yeah karma karma always strikes
so so that's so why did they have to
turn into a hit piece okay the agenda is
so clear again and then you can see you
can say the same of all the mainstream
media they're not seeking truth they're
not seeking genuine reporting they are
trying to push a predetermined agenda as
part of their whole leftist wokest you
know bending a knee to the leader of the
day which is this wokest ideology
there's no there's no genuine reporting
anymore none of them are interested in
the truth they all come with an agenda
and they try and get those gotcha
moments to push that agenda that's all
all of this reporting is it's quite
actually it's actually quite disgusting
also purely commercially if you were the
BBC or vice what if you did a
documentary that showed both the
positive and the negative Tates no one's
done that yet no that's something people
would watch not oh another hit piece
turn it off maybe we'll do that again
maybe we'll do that maybe we will
so let's get into this this war on
masculinity
[Music]
um because it's actually really sad like
as a woman I think it's sad I'm like
where are the men like where are they
you know where where are they you want
that that stoicism you want to be led
you want to be looked after
um obviously you're a little bit older
than me so what was it like back in the
day I didn't know what was it like is
this is this is this a new war has it
always been like this what were the
Dynamics between men and women when you
were in your 20s see I'm not sure I'm
I'm 40 so I think we've we've got um I
can't really speak back in the day too
much I don't think 20 years ago
world.com the world has changed so much
even in the last 10 years the world has
changed so much like we didn't have we
didn't have all this crazy
trans stuff 10 years ago that's pretty
new yeah
to be honest I'm not really sure in that
for my 20s I was just working and I was
moving constantly and I was spending
most of my time in countries where
you're not really going to be dating
let's put it that way yeah you gotta
gotta watch out
um but what I have seen is the DraStic
like exponential curve in the attack on
the family unit the attack on
traditional gender roles it's really
gone in a hyperdrive you cannot watch a
Hollywood movie now without getting
assaulted with what is essentially
psychological operations it's a psyop
they're trying to program things into
you and I really feel sorry especially
for women in today's day and age I mean
men can get on a base level what they
want it's very easy to get laid if
that's what drives you as a man is
everywhere but for a woman to find a
good caring man who embodies those
Traditional Values and will protect and
provide I think it's getting
increasingly difficult to do it and I
think the only way you're really going
to find it nowadays is through men who
have you know aligned themselves with
their faith if you as a man growing up
don't subscribe to a certain faith that
keeps you you know away from Temptation
temptation's there and it's so easy
you're going to engage in these things
you're going to be led by Hedonism and
so on as so many men are today so yeah I
really do uh
I empathize with women looking for that
traditional man because it's extremely
rare nowadays I'd say you have to look
at religious communities because how
else would a man stay on that straight
path and and want to enter into a
traditional relationship I think a lot
of men want the traditional woman
submissive caring you know supportive
but I don't see that many men prepared
to give their side of things which is a
lot like as a man to be able to properly
take care of a woman you need to have
your money right you need to have your
time right you need to have that that
emotional awareness in order to lead and
to to lead the family unit that's a lot
of responsibility and I think most men
nowadays are like I could do that or I
could just go on Tinder and get
unlimited Hedonism so it's a tricky one
so on that point about this like
unlimited hedonism
doesn't it get tiring 100 so um say a
man's been doing even like okay say he
starts getting his money right when he's
like 28 or whatever
he's been sleeping around from 28 to 35
let's just say
isn't that just so empty and tiring like
doesn't he just want like one woman
who's just gonna be there okay so no
high value man's ever gonna want one
woman that's a bit of a myth I'm not
sure if you want to bury it down on that
so throughout history and throughout
many cultures today and even I said this
to our man in Vice and he tried to say
it was misogynistic I mean history is
history the The Village Elder the guy at
the top who's able to look after
multiple families typically he'll do
that so one could argue the natural
state for a man with options is to enjoy
those options the question is how does
he do it does he do it running through
endless skanks or does he do it in a
healthy way where he's managing multiple
families you can see in many cultures
you can see in the Islamic World there
are healthy ways with which to express
that urge so I think for those men who
really want to be the man and have a
bunch of women get your life together to
the point where you can do that in a
healthy legal clean way but I think the
issue is nowadays because that takes a
lot of effort right yeah the issue is
notice it's a lot easier to just never
stop chasing and there's a lot of thirst
and I think as part of the societal
programming to make men thirsty the
songs you listen to the movies it's all
these men I've only get this girl then
I'll be happy or don't leave me all this
thirsty blue pill programming we see
being pushed on men I think it's worked
I know a lot of very successful men who
should get sick of that chase I got sick
of it years ago I don't run through
endless skanks I think it's empty and
boring to your point but I know a lot of
successful men who are getting bored of
that and that's just their model or
they'll be they'll be do they have to
have like do they have to be some level
of like damage to I I don't think so I
think every man on a deep level wants
sexual variety and I know that women of
today don't want to acknowledge that but
that's a biological fact and when you
look at the way the species is designed
a man can do his part of of you know of
insemination three four times a day is
fine if a woman gets pregnant that's
nine months of vulnerability and then
years and years of vulnerability
essentially so there's a lot more
potential consequences if we look at it
you know without the whole abortion
debate and all these things in
contraception a woman is a lot more
vulnerable when it comes to the sex act
and the implications that come from that
than a man is you know if we look in
yeah of course the old school context so
a lot of men there's no reason not to
and so they're just they just engage in
that uh forever of course it's a lot
more meaningful when you're with someone
that you love but what I would say is
the idea that a high value man is going
to conquer in business he's going to be
the man he's going to be attractive he's
going to be capable he's going to be
masculine but when it comes to woman
he's going to do exactly what you say
and only be with you that's a bit of a
myth as well and so I think it's any
woman who's searching for that high
value man again who wants him to be the
man in every every way but when it comes
to what he does with his dick he's going
to answer to you and do what you tell
him
I haven't seen that work and again rich
men just go on business trips and
exercise their their options that way
like the idea that men are happy is when
as in monogamous relationships high
value men they'd probably need to have
their testosterone checked and again I
don't want to say anything I mean okay
I'm saying things that people don't like
through my lived experience high value
men with their money right masculine
capable fit all these things they are
they're going to have many options and
then they're going to exercise those
options it's just about how they do it
okay so several questions first question
is can you have too many wives like is
there is there a limit
can you and are you required to give all
wife the same level of attention within
Islam you need to give the same level
attention to all and that's a challenge
so there must be a limit on how many
wives you could use it's four it's four
legally um and to be honest it doesn't
happen that often just because it's so
much work right I was gonna say I'm one
woman and I'm a lot yeah exactly isn't
that the truth um but no so yeah in the
Islamic context it's four um I think
what most high value men do is that
they'll have you know the marriage and
the normal house life but then they'll
travel and they'll you know exercise
their options in other ways like I don't
know any high value men who are still
fit and still about it as men who are
happy being monogamous they might have a
loving wife who they take care of in
every way but they're still going to
quietly exercise their options that's
just biology and and
trust me if I could turn that off if I
think if men could be happy just with
one woman we might choose that because
that'd be a lot easier don't be a lot
less hassle but on a deep level it's
there now I think men should have some
self-control I think men shouldn't just
be led by you know the lower brain and
they should have some ethics and if
they're going to pursue variety they
should do it in in a way that is is
clean and safe and all these different
things but um I don't know any high
value man who was happy with monogamy
and I think that's how we are as a
species I still think men have the
responsibility to control that and not
be led by that but that's there that
that's that's if you want that
Traditional High value man
I mean Tate talks about this you want
the Toyota it's going to be reliable all
the time go get the Toyota but women
don't want the Toyota they want the
Ferrari and guess what Ferraris they're
expensive they have maintenance issues
you need to accept some things when you
have the Ferrari that's what I've seen
through lived experience some people
might disagree with it but that's that's
what I've seen uh with with my 40 years
on this planet
findings I know we're tied for time
which is annoying um but I want to get I
just want to finish on the topic of the
war on masculinity I want to uncover I
guess your take on
what is the purpose behind it and who do
you think is behind this War I think
it's pure control I think corporations
want people easily controlled because
then the marketing messages will work
you know if you're deeply unhappy inside
then you're more prone to buy what they
tell you to buy because it'll make you
feel better I think governments want
people to be controlled because then the
fear campaigns will work you know
there's a lot more of us than there are
of the elite if you're the elite the
main game is keeping your power keeping
your wealth it is in your best interest
if the people are sheep what's the
number one issue with people being sheep
it's masculinity men who are free
thinking who have you know are in touch
with faith so they don't answer to the
government the answer to you know
they're good who have a strong family
unit
they're not going to be as susceptible
to the marketing messages they're not
going to be as impacted by the
government control fear levers being
pulled that's why you see nowadays
anything about free thinking masculinity
you know questioning the narrative men
banding together all of that's being
absolutely pushed down because that is a
very strong threat to you know ultimate
control of the population that's how
everyone I agree I always say that if we
live in a time where men were more
masculine
um and you know women didn't have to do
their part and rise up or whatever I
think that the lockdowns and the pushed
medicines and all that I don't think
they would have gotten away with it 100
and to me it's I mean Australia being an
example Melbourne was locked down for
nine months it's crazy like people stuck
in the house for nine months you know
small businesses Rule and all these
sorts of things you can look online and
see the street cameras in somewhere like
Sweden see that people are walking
around but no one does that and then the
person who pushed that you know dictated
Dan as they call him Dan Andrews he was
just voted in again by the majority it's
mind-bending and that that to your point
speaks to the fact that free independent
thought you know masculine men who are
prepared to stand up and rise up has
been absolutely crushed out of that
Society I've spent six weeks in
Australia in the last 15 years okay
ideologically I'm repulsed by what I see
down there Such a Pity that's what
that's what blows my mind it's you know
you have to live by your own um lived
experiences and you know I walked around
I traveled and I didn't see anyone
dropping dead I didn't see any I didn't
see anything or what I did see was
nurses dancing on Tick Tock I did see
that and so I don't understand how these
people you know voted down back in again
it makes no sense to me it it is proof
for the fact that the war on masculinity
The Matrix programming that this push to
make people sheep is working in the
majority of cases is working and it's
because the left controls the
information flow they control everything
from media to Netflix to social media
you name it uh so I don't I don't see
how we're going to defeat wokism other
than just all right all you sheep you go
live how you want to live yes a few of
us can live a bit of a different way
yeah I don't think the sheep can be
saved at this point I agree with you I
think we're moving into two parallel
societies and um I think with people
like yourself with the Tates you're
waking people up and so that's why when
when how about you I try my best but you
know I think you guys are obviously
doing a much louder bigger job and I
think it's amazing and that's why I was
so loud
um in supporting Tate because I think
what he's doing and what you guys are
doing is so important um also I know my
brother has a question he's been dying
to ask you about a Bugatti or something
so get you want to ask this question
yes so I know a lot of Tate's assets
cars other things got seized but I know
there was because we saw the videos I
think there was rolls royces McLarens
but I know the Bugatti might be
somewhere secretly I was just wondering
you don't have to answer specifically
the question but
is it in the custody of the Romanian
authorities or whoever else or is it
somewhere safe okay well that's all I
want to know I mean because it's a
Bugatti and I like it indeed indeed what
I would say to answer that question I
ask a question if they had seized the
Bugatti would they not put photos of
that seizure everywhere thank you I'll
answer the question okay the one of 60
is safe that's great to know that's all
I wanted to know good stuff I need to
confirm or deny just you know deductive
reasoning we would have seen a lot of it
if they actually got it that's that's
that's that's my belief yeah yeah no
that's smart okay that's great to know
thank you so before all this uh I call
it red pill Andrew Tate stuff or
whatever
um I am like really big in crypto I love
Bitcoin love freedom I think it's an
amazing tool to help enable Freedom so
I'm curious are you into crypto I know
like take talks about Bitcoin and stuff
like that are you interested in crypto
do you own anything that you can share
with us um not really I've got a little
over seven figures in in crypto I don't
consider myself a big crypto that's a
lot what do you mean
a significant place so to speak but I
think it's definitely worth putting um
some assets into that I'm also a big
believer in property in countries where
governments will leave you alone
which countries are that this is where I
talk about the UAE so people people talk
about being yeah I like your expression
there oh but we have freedom in America
it's not free over there if you put put
your head above you know the parapet so
to speak if you say things you're not
allowed to say if you go to a certain
level the government here will come
after you in a big way the work mob will
cancel you in the UAE as long as you
don't criticize religion don't criticize
the government which is something I
would never do anyway
then you you get left alone you can live
well be a good citizen go about your
business the system doesn't come after
you you are allowed to have conservative
values you are allowed to say I don't
agree with
men dressed in women's clothing dancing
around in schools and indeed the
government agrees with you so I I'm a
big believer in buying property as well
because look I love all things virtual I
also like things I can live in like you
know I like things I can touch
um you know palpable assets I I do like
gold I mean I think of these as you can
turn this into Cash anytime you know
this is a contingency plan on the wrist
so to speak and I've got more in in this
than I do in crypto to be honest uh in
watches just because it is that easy
turn back into cash and during a bull
run it actually performs sort of in
parallel with crypto to be honest
but if you have property in countries
and and you're on multiple grids in
countries that leave you alone as long
as you follow the rules I think that's a
great play too I feel a lot more free in
the UAE as the sort of man than I am
with the traditional values that I have
with the way I want to live my life than
I do in the US if you if you have any if
you have any role or any sort of public
face and you say certain things in the
US they will come after you that to me
is not Freedom you know work mob will
come after you can lose your job walking
down the street in somewhere like London
with a nice watch someone come at you
with a hammer to me that's not freedom
being in a situation where you have to
be very conscious of the agendas being
pushed on your kids Minds in school that
to me is not Freedom doesn't happen in
the UAE so again in all these different
metrics if we want to talk about genuine
freedom to live the way you want to live
for people like us I look at the UAE as
vastly more free than any of these
Western cities and that's where I
believe building property as as a you
know counter play to Virtual assets
makes a lot of sense that's really
interesting to hear because I was I
understand that the UAE is free and the
government aren't coming after you I get
that but I was always under the
impression that if you did something
wrong or somebody framed you and then
the government believed that you did
something wrong then they could
potentially take back the land I was
under the impression that they still
owned it even though you bought it but
perhaps I'm wrong not at all so Europe
the idea the government will leave you
alone be a good citizen you have to work
hard to get in trouble in UAE you'd have
to publicly say really negative things
or do crude sexual acts in public or you
have to work hard to get in any any
trouble the way the government works
over there is you be a good citizen you
can live here if not we'll kick you out
done I like that it's like the whole
country has some form of access control
and from a security risk management
perspective it's a very well-run country
I feel a lot more free with as a man
with Traditional Values and the beliefs
that I have in the UAE than I would in
any Western Country and indeed that's
why I live there I guess it means I need
to move to the UAE then there you go
come over guys I'll host you there we go
shooting again you need to beat your
sister next time brother she she shot
better than you man
they say women are better Shooters I
don't know
um but Jill
I want to thank you so much um for
coming on it's been so interesting
hearing about your background learning
about your relationship with Andrew
um so yeah I want to thank you so much
awesome let's do this again in Dubai
I'll sort everything out we'd love to
host you guys thank you for everything
you do to support Andrew I really I
really respect that indeed that's why
I'm here and wanting to talk to you so
thank you my pleasure thank you both
cheers guys thanks so much for watching
if you enjoyed this episode please don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe and of course follow satorial
shooter all over the Internet you can
stay up to date with everything that's
going on with Andrew